MARTIN PLAYING HIS SEVENTH
CAREER NDER
WAY TONIGHT IN BENIERS.
WAY DOWN. CLEAN
SHOOTING CHANCE ANDND
>> Brendan: BRINGS THATRNOVER A
CONOR GARLAND.
HE GOES WIDEZONE.
DACCORD ONCE AGAIN OUT OF HIS
THE HIGH  SEND IT ALL THE
WAY BACK BEHIND THE CANUCK NET.S
ON THE  POKE
AND THEY WEREN'T USING IT.
BUT WITH TIME RUNNING
CHOLOWSKI BEHIND HIS OWN NET
NEAR SI
IF THEY CAN GET A LITTL WIDE.
SCHENN GETS IT ON THE NEAR
PASSING LANE ON THE P.K. HE'S A
HOLD AS EKMAN-LARSSON CLEARS THE
FRONT OF THENG...RE AGAIN.
THIS TIME IT WAS BENIERS AND HE
DOESN'T HAVE HIS STICK!
SPRONG AGAIN WITHH
YOUR BEST PENALTY KILLER AND HE
HAS BEEN IN THIS GAME AS HUGHES
GETS IT TO THE LINE.
HELD I JARED McCANN ARE THE
BOARDS.
GEEKIE FINDS LARSSON.
AND HE'LL BRING IT THROUGH THE
CENTRE ICE CIRCLE TO THE RED
CANUCKS, AFTER ALL THE PENALTYT
BOARDS LEAVES FOR WENNBERG AT
THE LINE, MARTIN, THAT
SECOND PERIOD KEPT HIS TEAM
AHEAD.
THE FORMER EDMONTON OILER AS A
LITTLE BIT OF NET-FRONT TRAFFIC
AND STOPPED ITOTH
PETAN AND LAMMIKKO ON THE
AGAIN FOR BENIERS WHO TIPS IT IN
HERE'S THE SHOT.
LOOK AT LUKE
CIRCLE PASS THROUGH THE SLOT
COMES TO GARLAND AND HERE COME
THE CANUCKS TWO- FOR
QUINN HUGHES.
BRUCE BOUDREAU TALKED ABOUT